MARTIN: Hi, Mete.
METE: Hi, Martin,
what's going on?
MARTIN: I loaded some e-commerce
order data into BigQuery.
Now I want to
transform that data
and create a new table that's
optimized for my business
intelligence dashboard.
Somebody told me you might have
pointers for how to do that.
METE: Yes, you
should check out DBT.
It's a third party tool to
transform data by simply
writing select statements.
It doesn't extract
or load data but it
is extremely good
at transforming
data that's already loaded
into your warehouse.
MARTIN: Cool!
Will do.
[THEME MUSIC]
Hi, Mete.
Thanks for your tip about DBT.
I found a really nice tutorial
on how to transform data
within BigQuery.
It does pretty much what I need.
It joins a customer
and an order table
into a new dashboard
friendly table.
I got it working on my Google
Cloud account, can I show you?
METE: Sure, let's see.
MARTIN: All right, I'll
switch over here to this.
I'll go into the jaffle
shop example that I loaded.
I'm running DBT Run.
We'll see if it runs.
So there, it says
completed successfully.
And if I go over to my
project and I go into BigQuery
and I go into my
customers' data set here.
I have a table and
a customer table
that was created by this job.
I click Preview and
sure enough, there's
my denormalized customer data.
METE: Good job, Martin.
But I have one question.
How are you going to run
this in the long run?
I can imagine typing DBT
Run every day will get old
pretty quickly.
Also, you probably
want BigQuery to always
have the latest data even
when you're out on vacation.
MARTIN: OK.
Well, I guess I could trigger
the command on a schedule
from a cron job on my laptop.
METE: Wouldn't your laptop be
closed when you're on vacation?
MARTIN: Maybe I could
get a virtual machine
to run this in the Cloud.
METE: You could, but why keep
a virtual machine running 24/7
when you only need for
a few seconds per day?
And you probably don't want to
add server maintenance to your
to do list.
MARTIN: Ugh, I hate
managing servers.
I'm not good at it.
METE: Let's go
serverless instead.
MARTIN: But how would I
run a custom command line
tool from a serverless
product like Cloud Functions?
The Cloud Functions runtime
doesn't have DBT installed.
METE: That's true, but
we have other options.
In Cloud Run you can create your
own runtime with a container.
There's a base container
image with DBT,
we can start with that.
MARTIN: That sounds great.
How do I set that up?
METE: Open your Google Cloud
project and I'll show you.
MARTIN: All right, so
I'm here in my project.
METE: Cloud Run lets
you run containers
without having to
maintain a server
and you only pay
when your code runs.
MARTIN: Cool!
But I don't know much about
containers or .go As a matter
of fact, I don't even have .go
installed here on my laptop.
METE: No worries, we'll
build the container
using Cloud Build.
Your code in Cloud Run is
triggered by HTTP requests.
In this case, we will
run the DBT command
in a shell script in
response to an HTTP request.
Let's find a simple HTTP server
that can run shell scripts.
Go to Cloud Run tutorial
and find a sample
for running a shell
script in Cloud Run
and copy that code
to your machine.
MARTIN: OK, so I'm
in the quick start
for build and
deploy on Cloud Run.
Scrolling down the page here,
I want to run a shell script.
Here's a shell script.
OK, it seems like there
is a Go program here
that can run shell scripts.
So I copy that, I paste
that into my machine.
OK, I've saved it as
invoke.go on my machine.
METE: Cool.
Then save your comment
in a script file.
MARTIN: All right.
I did that already.
I have a script.sh
here on my machine.
METE: Now let's
containerize our code.
I sent you a .go file
for the container image.
We are relying on a base image
that includes the DBT tool.
We are also copying the go HTTP
server along with the script
file to the container.
The entry point to the
container is the HTTP server.
Let's build the container
with Cloud Build,
I sent you the command
for doing that.
MARTIN: All right.
You sent me, let's
see, build container.
So I'm running that now.
All right, it finished
building the container.
METE: Let's deploy the
container to Cloud Run.
That's the second
command I have sent you.
MARTIN: All right.
I got it.
So deploy container, very good.
I'm running that now.
All right.
The script for deploying
container finished running.
So it says something about
serving traffic 100% at URL
and there's a URL with a
strange hash code in it.
What's this URL?
METE: That's the service URL.
When you hit that URL, the
code you just uploaded runs.
Try it!
MARTIN: Oh, cool.
All right.
So I'm going to my browser here,
pasting it in, and running it.
Let's see what happens.
Oh, cool.
So I see the printout that I
previously got from my DBT job
in my console, I now see
that in my web browser.
And let's see, if I go over
to BigQuery and refresh here.
I open my customers data set,
click the customer table,
and let's see.
There is a table
there, I click Preview.
And sure enough, there's my
denormalized customer table,
including order
dates and everything.
METE: Nice.
MARTIN: Great.
All right.
So let me delete this
table again to make sure
that we can recreate it.
Customers, delete.
So I moved my DBT job from
my laptop to the Cloud.
I can run the DBT
job by hitting URL,
but I still have to manual
hit that URL from my browser.
The job won't run by itself
when I'm on vacation.
METE: That's right,
but we can fix that.
Cloud Scheduler is a service
that can trigger an end
point on a given schedule.
Let's go to Cloud Scheduler
page and create a new job.
MARTIN: All right, I'm
clicking Cloud Scheduler here.
Create new job, and, OK, so I
have a bunch of fields here.
I guess for a name I'll say,
right, DBT job, perhaps.
Frequency, this is something
with stars and numbers.
What's this about Mete?
METE: So that's the frequency
that the Cloud Scheduler
will call your service.
It's in cron format.
So I guess in this case, we want
to run it once a day every day
in the afternoon.
So we will enter something
like 016, star, star.
MARTIN: Very good, I did that.
And let's see, time zone.
I want it to be in my time zone.
I'm in the Pacific, US
Pacific Standard Time.
Oh and I needed to
fix the name here.
All right, so Mete,
the next one is target.
So I can choose between HTTP,
pub sub, and App Engine HTTP.
What should I pick here?
METE: So in this case, we
want to hit a Cloud Run
service, which is an HTTP end
point, so we'll choose HTTP.
MARTIN: Oh, OK.
HTTP it is.
And for URL, I guess I
should paste in that URL
that I hit manually before?
METE: Yes, that's the
Cloud Run service URL.
MARTIN: Excellent.
And if I remember correctly I
hit it with a git, with a post.
I'm clicking Create here.
And look, there's my new job.
METE: Yes, it's created
but it's not running yet.
We can actually test it out
by just clicking the run now
button to trigger it manually.
MARTIN: Oh, cool.
OK, I'm clicking Run now.
Uh-huh, very good.
Something happened.
All right, so I'm going into
my project here in BigQuery.
I see the customers
data set there
and there's the customers
table that I deleted before.
It has been recreated.
Let's just have a look at
the preview of that table.
And yep, there is my
denormalized order data.
Table is there,
everything is working.
But Mete, I'm accessing this
from an incognito window.
I just hit the URL here
and it just came through.
Can anyone access that
URL and run my job?
METE: That's right, it's
a public service right now
but we can make it private so
only authenticated users can
access it.
Then we can configure
class schedules
to use a service account to
access this private service.
I have written a
tutorial that explains
how to do that, the link is
in the description below.
MARTIN: OK, so let's
summarize what we did.
We started with
Cloud Scheduler that
hit a URL on a schedule that
triggered a Cloud Run job.
That Cloud Run job ran a script
file, a shell script file,
which in turn is running a
DBT command that updates,
transforms the data in my
BigQuery data warehouse.
METE: Exactly!
And the key point is that we
run DBT commands without having
to maintain servers and
we run it on a schedule
so that you don't need to be
around to trigger it every day.
MARTIN: I like that I
don't have to remember
to run this every day manually.
METE: Now you can
go back to the beach
without having to think
about service, Martin.
[CHUCKLES]
[THEME MUSIC]